the Silicon Valley and the internet gave
me superpowers tools to go to battle
with a suit to take bullets with and the
giant signal in the sky that told me
when it was time to fight now I can't
actually prove any of this I am NOT a
scientist I don't have facts in fact my
rod tomato scores running around 50
percent right now so I'm not sure why
they let me in but if we're talking
about colliding with a power that's
bigger than us
then I'm in the right place because this
last year I had an interesting year with
a movie called crazy rich Asians that I
did thank you thank you and if we're
talking about connection specifically
today that I know my story is only
possible because of a collection of
connections that happen throughout my
life and so hopefully by telling a
little bit of my story it'll help
someone else find their path a little
sooner than I did so my story begins
when I open the holy book for the first
time the holy book of gadgets of course
sharper image for anyway yes those who
know it was a magical magazine of dreams
and had things in there that you knew
could not possibly exist but it was
right there you could order it come in
the mail and some things that probably
should have never existed like Gregory
uh-huh a life like portable mannequin
who deters crime by his strong masculine
appearance this is a real is a real
thing by the way but my eyes were set on
the video edit
sima - this thing was so cool at the age
of 10 you could connect all your VHS
players together and cut something
together so I call my parents and
convince them to buy this for me but
before I get into that let me give you a
little rundown about my parents they
came to the United States when they're
young they're from Taiwan and China and
settled in Los Altos California the
Silicon Valley before the Silicon Valley
and they start a restaurant called chef
choo's 50 years later today they still
work at the restaurant they're still
there and I grew up there so it was
great it was talk about connection this
place was a hub of connection people
coming there to celebrate birthdays
anniversaries business deals eating
drinking connection and I got to grow up
in that environment and my parents
always said America is the greatest
place in the world you can if you love
anything you can work hard and you can
accomplish anything you want so they
raised five all-american kids I am the
youngest you can see I'm the one with
the eyes closed there and and they named
actually my sister and I Jennifer and
Jonathan after Jennifer and Jonathan
Hart from that TV show heart to heart so
that's how much they loved America
apparently and they thought that we were
the Kennedys my mom specifically so she
dressed us up all the time like each
other and she put us in etiquette
classes and ballroom dance classes made
sure that we had the right dental plan
this is a real picture I mean that is
not fake thank God for that one and I
was in charge of the video camera every
time we went on vacation so I would
collect all these videos and nothing to
do with it thus the cyma video edit -
and so I convinced them to get it for me
and I all night spent trying to wrangle
all the VCRs for my brother and sisters
room tangled and wires and now I had
something to show them so I brought them
into the living room one night that's
probably in 1991 somewhere out there and
I sit them down in the living room and I
was my heart was pounding my breasts
were deep sort of like right now and I
press play and something extraordinary
happened actually they cried and cried
they cried not because it was the most
amazing home video edit ever although it
was pretty good but because they saw our
family as a normal family that fit in
and belonged on the screen in front of
them just like the movies that they
worshiped and the TV shows that they
named us after and I remember as
youngest of these five kids fee
heard for the first time this is place
where all these things in my head could
go into the great electric somewhere out
there and exists and escape and I knew
from this moment on I wanted to do this
for the rest of my life whether I was
going to get paid for it or not and so I
had this passion and now I needed some
tools and my dad went to work he he
continued to brag about my home video
editing skills to the customers at chef
choo's and luckily this is the Silicon
Valley so they were working on stuff a
hardware and software these are all
engineers and they offered to give me
things for digital video editing this is
this is like the mid nineties early
nineties where they didn't the stuff
didn't exist for kids like me so I'd get
these beta software and hardware from
places like HP and Sun and and Russell
Brown at Adobe literally I get and I had
no manual so I'd figure it out and I
fell in love with it even more so I went
to a USC School of Cinematic Arts and
started to go there and and my mom and
dad would always call me randomly and
remind me that I've got to do movies
about my Chinese heritage that China was
gonna be a huge market for movies one
day I was like yeah right yeah all right
guys always listen to your parents and I
wanted to be Zemeckis Lucas and
Spielberg the last thing I wanted to
talk about was my own cultural identity
my ethnicity and honestly I had no one
else to talk about there was no one at
school that I could really open up to
and even if I did like what would I say
so I ignored it and I moved on with my
life cut to 15 years later I made it in
Hollywood I I got discovered by
Spielberg I worked with the rock and
Bruce Willis and Justin Bieber I even
came to the Ted stage to present my
dance company lxd and it was great and
then a couple years ago I felt a little
bit lost creatively the engine was sort
of going down a little bit and I got a
sign I heard some voices from the sky
and what more is like birds okay fine it
was Twitter and in Twitter
it was Constance Wu on Twitter it was
Daniel Dae Kim
it was Jenny yang who's here today it's
Alan yang all these people who were
writing their frustrations with
representation in Hollywood and it
really hit me I thought these things but
never really registered I was really
focused on I felt lucky to be working
and so then I realized yeah what is
wrong with Hollywood why aren't they
doing this and then I looked at myself
in the mirror and realized I am
Hollywood I literally I'm so hot I pop
my collar before I came out here that's
how Hollywood I am still up it was still
up okay good and you know for all these
years I felt just I've been given so
much and what was I giving back to the
film business that I that I loved and I
felt lucky to be here but at this moment
I realized that I was not just lucky to
be here I had the right to be here
no I earned the right to be here all
those sleepless nights all those parties
I missed on Fridays every fit a friend
and girlfriend I lost because I was
editing I earned the right to be here
not just to have a voice but to say
something and say something important
and I have actually the power the power
the super power to change things if I
really really wanted to all those you
know when you try to tell stories about
yourself and people who look like you
and look like your family it can be
scary and all those feelings of being
alone came back but the Internet is what
told me sent this sign that there was
gonna be a whole army waiting for me to
support me and to love me for it and so
I found Kevin Kwan's amazing novel crazy
rich Asians and we went to work and we
put this movie together the Asian cast
the first all Asian cast in 25 years
with a contemporary story yeah
but when when we started it was not it
was on a guarantee at at all
there was no comp for this kind of movie
all the every time we did surveys and
stuff the audiences weren't going to
show up and in fact even in our test
screenings where you give free tickets
to be able to watch your movie we've had
a one to twenty five ratio meaning after
twenty-five ask only one person said yes
which is super low for these types of
things Asian people who knew the book
didn't trust Hollywood at all Asian
people who didn't know the books thought
the title was offensive and other people
who weren't asian just didn't think it
was for them so we were pretty screwed
but luckily Warner Brothers didn't turn
away from us but then the electric some
were struck again and this army of Asian
American writers reporters bloggers who
sort of over the years had worked their
way up through their respective
publications went to work unbeknownst to
me and they started to post things and
also some tech founders out here it sort
of post stuff on social media write
stuff about us in in articles in the LA
Times in Holly Reporter and
Entertainment Weekly it was like this
grassroots uprising of making ourselves
news what an amazing thing to witness
and the swell of support turned into
this conversation online
between all these asian-americans where
we could actually debate and discuss
what stories we wanted to tell what
stories should be told or not what kind
of are we allowed to make fun of
ourselves what's about what about
casting what are we allowed to do and we
didn't agree and we still don't but that
listens that was in the point the point
was the conversation was happening and
this conversation sort of stream became
an infrastructure it took all these
different groups that were trying to
achieve she's the same thing and put us
all together in this connective tissue
and again not perfect but the start of
how we determine our own representation
on the big screen it became more
physical when I went to the movie
theater and I'll never forget going
opening weekend and I went into the
theater and it's all not just Asians all
types of people and I go and I sit down
to people people laughed people cried
and when I went into the to the lobby
people stayed it's like they didn't want
to leave
they just hugged each other high-five
each other took selfies they debated it
they laughed about all these different
things and you know I had such an
intimate relationship with his movie Lee
but I didn't understand what we were
making it when we were making it what we
were making until it was happening that
I mean the only it was the same thing
that my parents felt when they watched
our family videos in that living room
that day seeing us on the screen has a
power to it and the only I could
describe this is pride I I've always
understood this word intellectually I've
probably talked about this word but to
actually feel pride and those of you who
have felt it know it's like you just
want to like touch everybody and like
grab and like run around it's like a
very I can't explain it's just a very
physical feeling all because of a long
pattern of connection film was a you
know gift given to me and through the
years I've learned a lot of things you
can plan you can write scripts you can
do your storyboards but a certain point
your movie will speak back to you and
it's your job to listen it's this living
organism and it sort of presents itself
so you better catch it before it slips
through your hands and that's the most
exciting part about making movies and
when I look at life it's not that
different actually that I've been led
through these sort of breadcrumbs of of
connections that have through people
through circumstances through luck and
it changed when I realized that once you
start listening and to the silent beats
and the messy noises around you you
realize that there's this beautiful
symphony already written for you a
direct line to your destiny your
superpower
now film was a gift given to me sort of
spurned all my parents and supported by
my community I got to be who I wanted to
be when I needed to be it
my mom posted something on Facebook the
other day which is usually really bad
things to say how loud be scary she
should not have a Facebook but she
posted this thing and it was a meme you
know one of those funny things and it
said you can't change someone who
doesn't want to change but I never
underestimate the power of planting a
seed and as I was doing the finishing
touches of this talk I realized that all
the powerful connections in my life were
through generosity and kindness and love
and hope so when I think about my movies
crazy rich Asians and in the heights
which I'm working on right now all yeah
good one all I want to do is show joy
and hope into them because I refuse to
believe that our best days are behind us
but in fact around the corner because
you see love love is the superpower that
was given to me love is the is the
superpower that was that was passed on
to me love is the only thing that can
stop a speeding bullet before it even
exits the chamber love is the only thing
that can leap over a building and have a
whole community look up into the sky
join hands and have the courage to face
something that's impossibly bigger than
themselves so I have a challenge for
myself and for anyone here as you're
working on your your thing on your
company and you're forging this thing to
life and you're making the impossible
possible let's just not forget to be
kind to each other because I believe
that is the most powerful form of
connection we can give to this planet in
fact our future depends on it thank you
[Applause]